α να προχωρήσετε στην ύτρηση της μετοχεμ ο καιρός όπως σα θυμάστε η μπορεί να
ξέρετε ήταν δύσκολος δύο χρόνια μετά την ιτουρκική ζολή τουργικής βολη μας άφησε πρακτικά όταν
να έγινε χωρίς φάρμακα γιατί εκτός από τα λίγα που υπήρχαν στα διάφορα φαρομαγία της
εναπό μή να σας κύπρου τα αποθέματα της κυβέρνησης ήταν σε αποηθήκες που είχαν καταλιυθεί
από τους τουρκους και στον πόλεμο πρέπει κανίνα ξέρει ότι δεν μπορείς να κάνεις πολεμου
χωρής φάρμακα δεν μπορείς ούτε να αντιμετωπίσεις επιθέσεις χωρίς φάρμακα και αυτό το πράγμα έχε
συμβή μερικός τότε στην κύπρο ευτύχος μας έστειλα ναπτη τελάδα με τα πρώτα καράβια που
ηθανορισμένα φάρμακα τα οποία διαναμήθηκαν εκεί που επρεπε όσο μπορούσε να αντιμετωποιηστεί αδιμετοβιστούν ι δυσχολίες
το κάναμε η απόφαση μου να δημιουργήσω τη μετοκαμί βασίζεται σε αυτό το γεγονός σχέφθηκα
ότι δεν μπορούμε να μείνουμε χωρής φάρμακα η κύπρος να μίνει χωρής επιτόπια φαρμακοβιομηχανία και
αυτό με οδήγησε στη δημιουργία της εταιρίας πρέπει να απόφυσικά ότι όταν έκανα φαρουμακολογία δούλευα
σε μια υστριακή εταιρία ίχα αποκομήσει αρχετές γνώσεις και απότε πουδεσμου αλλά και φυσικά δουλεύοντας
κυπα